ladies and gentlemen i'm retiring from
youtube that's right i'm done
susan's taken advantage of me for far
too long been paying her way too much
money
and i'm sick of it quite frankly and i
need to make this financial decision for
me
for my family like this 10 million
studio it's expensive
the first mortgage payment came in and
quite frankly i am drowning in debt and
enough is enough guys a man can only
take so much before he has to finally
throw in the towel
but before i do it i need to expose the
biggest con artists in the entire
fake guru industry i've never talked
about them because you know i didn't
want to burn any bridges
i knew that i wanted to be nice to these
guys i mean it's not even
just one it's actually a group of three
okay three people that i've never called
out because i'm afraid they have big
big shot lawyers um but it's finally
time i called them out
and those three people are tom
nashvilles or cornelia might quit
i know you guys thought we were all
friendly and stuff like that
but i was really like a little mole
inside their operation i was only
pretending so that i could later expose
them
for who they really are that's right
bring the screen down boys
spencer cornelia to start now many of
you may know spencer as a real estate
investor someone who's passionate
about finance but i see a photoshop
artist see he claims in his banner that
he was on wheel of fortune
his name but i looked through literally
thousands of hours of footage and
literally found
no mentions of the name spencer cornelia
additionally when you look at
below this i know a lot of people would
miss this little detail but it says
guru killa which rhymes i don't know if
you guys know this
with coffee zilla which can only mean
one thing
spencer cornelia may have blood on his
hands guys when caleb maddox went
missing
i always wondered i mean after my live
stream he said he was going to make
daily videos
he never did and i think at this point
even the police are asking
where is caleb maddox and does the guru
killa
have anything to do with it i don't know
if spencer did it
but let's just look in those eyes real
quick and i think we can make a pretty
reasonable
assumption next bridge i'm burning tom
nash this man
is a thumbnail plagiarist he has one
good thumbnail idea
and proceeds to plagiarize it off
himself for months
with no attribution disgusting and i get
it to the common man
you see six distinct thumbnails i see
six copies
next and this is this one actually hurts
mike win it
right many of you including myself were
fooled by this guy for a very long time
mike has a successful show called
entrepreneur bingo
i myself and many others were a fan of
this uh
where he's hanging out in this gigantic
office space you see him as successful
and you know popular but the truth is
far more sinister
see i was leaked by one of mike's
interns this
shocking photo this
is the real state of entrepreneur bingo
it's all been a green screen
we caught em boys we caught em who would
lie to their audience with something
like this let me just ask you this what
kind of psycho
would tell their audience months and
months for weeks and weeks that they're
somewhere they're not not me i've never
lied to you guys in my life i've never
been wrong about anything
and literally never known it was green
screen until the shocking footage came
out
um mike exposed now guys now that i've
burned those bridges there's no going
back
on this retirement there's no way i
could show my face in this circle again
so let's just go all the way through why
am i retiring because it's not just
randomly
i'm not doing this for no reason it's
because i recently learned
the truth about retirement that people
aren't going to tell you
um see i watched joshua fluke's video on
retirement you may know him he's been on
the podcast before
josh has a very mainstream view of
retirement let's
hear what it is this is what retirement
actually
looks like this is what retirement looks
like ladies and gentlemen this is what i
used to believe about retirement
that retirement means you're old but
that was back when i was a big dumb dumb
like josh flew and i didn't mean to
expose him there but josh sorry you're
in the crosshairs right now
everybody's getting it on retirement day
see joshua fluke is totally wrong about
retirement as are most people most
people think of retirement
as you save up money so that you can
retire i learned recently
that you have to retire to make enough
money to retire which is why i'm
retiring guys
welcome to my retirement video and why
you should retire
and yes we're four minutes and 30
seconds in and i'm just getting to the
point of this video but hold on guys
it's my retirement video i can do it how
i want
so this may be the most important little
slide deck you've ever seen
it's retirement 101 by coffeezilla
because if you're in the old model
you probably think that retirement is
for old people and that's the mistake
this
lie this false narrative is being mostly
propagated by one man
joshua fluke the youtuber the truth is
retirement's made to make you more money
and i know that's confusing to a lot of
you so let me explain see the truth is i
used to be negative towards retirement
too i mean like
back in the day a long time ago i was
downing people who did this
i was hating on them i was making fun of
them and their taglines
but that's before i knew the truth guys
that's before i got enlightened
i used to propagate the this poor
mindset this poor mentality
you know and that's how you stay poor is
by not retiring early
but luckily guys i'm a non-stop learner
so eventually i figured it out and it's
also a great way to get job security
guys because as the old saying goes
once you retire you can never be fired
now
i want you guys to know also get arm
yourself with evidence as they say
because all the greats have done it
listen conor mcgregor sure you know who
he is he retired
he said i have decided to retire young
thanks for the cheese catches later now
what happened years after he retired
after retiring from fighting he made the
most money he had ever made in his
career fighting
look this is the face of a man making a
lot of money i know it may not look like
it
but wow this is the face of a winner now
i know you're savvy and you want more
evidence fine evidence number two
we have linus tech tips ladies and
gentlemen this is a small little
youtuber who
thought of retiring 10 months ago he
announced it he got millions of views
the video went viral
uh because all of a sudden everyone
freaked out oh he's retiring he's
retiring
now look at him he's the number one tech
youtuber but maybe you're not into these
youtubers right you want to know about
traditional media maybe you don't trust
this new showbiz right take a look at
old showbiz jay leno was about to be
fired
so he retired he said he was handing
over the show to conan o'brien good luck
next week my friend jay thank you for
everything
and then he took it back yeah i'll take
the show back once you retire
you can never be fired guys there are
even people you may not have even known
or retired and are successful because of
it
this is pewdiepie i've already retired
he said
don't believe me roll the clip i've
already retired now look at him
look he's one of the biggest youtubers
now this is how you get successful guys
other big youtubers you may know morgs
obviously one of the greats on youtube
he retired sorry guys i'm sorry teamwork
i can't do this i'm quitting youtube
[Music]
now look at him guys this is just
a pattern of behavior i mean i don't
mean to shake you guys up with these
things but as uncle ben says
facts don't care about your feelings now
that just about covers it but i just
wanted to conclude for you guys a little
bit here
um i am retiring listen that's fact
number one i had to do it
for the sake of my career i decided i
was finally ready to get serious about
working
so i had to quit uh i also wanted to say
please smash like and subscribe guys
because big things are coming
in my retirement because i may be
quitting but it's just
the beginning